the Joe Rogan experience where the
weirdest [ __ ] was diego sanchez oh did i
centers at his last fight i don't know
who we trained with he left jackson
Winkle Winkle john i don't know if he
had training partners i don't know what
he did I think the one guy in his
corners tell him be like Tyson go out in
there and be like oh [ __ ] way who's
giving him weird advice
Diego was getting michael Chiesa was
just flowing on him
yeah it's flowing and every time diego
was able to capitalize on a position
like a slip-up or an window of
opportunity to get on top he just [ __ ]
it up and then he had just got right
back up creative scrambling and he was
right back in a dominant position once
again I was like yeah this is not gonna
end well I thought he's gonna get the
finish but the way you saw like Diego
Sanchez manhandle Mickey gall crazy then
the way you see michael Chiesa
manhandled Diego Sanchez he levels Wow
levels levels in size chiesa isn't
talked about a guy who cut too much
weight it is incredible that that dude
ever made 155 pounds
he's so large that is a big man so big
and when you put your hand on I'm like
I'm interviewing it's like a [ __ ]
piece of wood man yeah that's some
grappling constrictor strength you know
yeah he's a big dude man I saw him
before the fight in the PSN sounds like
to it I told him saying things like I
don't know I really do not know how the
[ __ ] you ever made 155 it's like
probably counterproductive for you to
even go down there yeah you just got
such a big frame you I think he would
Excel a 70 I think so too but what's
interesting is like he's done way better
at 70 than Kevin Lee has and Kevin Lee
beat him at 55 yeah
so it's it's crazy how like you got to
go up and wait but you also got to do it
the right way yeah I think he did it the
right way when he's at 170 he's super
healthy yeah strong dude man is so
famous like flows like the way he was
flowing with Diego he just he didn't
like tighten up he was in total control
he would take chances he would roll in
the crucifix positions he would lose it
and get a hold of him again again yeah
I'm down Slyke it was like a black belt
wrong with a blue belt that's what it
was like I was like
this is crazy - why or Capel belt easy
to watch it's different man it's really
levels to the game and it's also size
size takeaways 169 like the day before
the fight wasn't didn't have to cut any
weight at all whereas kis are probably
in the 190s you look huge I I wonder
what makes him want to go down to 55
then if that's not as nice go down to 55
what is this Jamie this is voodoo coach
oh no one else this dude has no
experience as an MMA coach by the way so
this is the dude that's telling them to
be like Tyson he's been like water right
now you slip the slip well touch but
touch but do such a strange guy man he
might believe that this dude has masked
magic powers cuz he was talking about
but I think a big part Diego success is
his belief system right Diego just
believes things dude this guy's amazing
what technique oh come on son show me
that Oh bro so good imagine looking at
this guy and go listen [ __ ] Longo and
Sarah that would actually be a good like
skit like yeah I'm going out to Train
like just had the whole thing leading up
to it and then let him know like I was
just [ __ ] around you know well I
think that's what Anderson Silva did
when he brought in Steven Seagal
complete joke I'm gonna people were
buying it well well Segal was selling it
he was selling it you know I was like
that's a technique that I taught
Anderson Oh bro okay front kick
everybody knows that one that's day one
white belt class oh man that I can't
believe people bought it for so long
it's almost like the Ronda Rousey - yes
look at this ooh
karate change the head son imagine these
dudes standing there while he practices
all this [ __ ] there's George George they
all had to do it with a straight face oh
yeah it's like the ultimate roll
Anderson's practicing it it's acting is
so good this is like a you know what
this is like this is like like a break
DeMarcus clown
given Dave Chappelle comedy technique
there's some dude whose is like a hey so
you gotta get a nose it's really what
it's like it's like dave chappelle
getting comedy technique from a clown
the that reminds me of the Napoleon
Dynamite Wayne he's like would you want
to get kicked by me in these pants break
the wrist walk away
[Applause]